this guy's 70 years old he just gave me
accumulated knowledge of 50 years
I just saved 50 years in one hour that's
a mentor here we are on the bench
Shapiro's Sunday special and we are here
with tylo PES you can check out all of
his stuff at Tai Lopez comm slash ben
shapiro is a brand new program called
knowledge society we're going to talk
about plus everything else on earth but
first let's talk about your internet
security with all the recent news about
online security breaches it's hard not
to worry about where my data goes making
an online purchase simply accessing your
email could put your private information
at risk you are being tracked online by
social media sites and marketing
companies and your mobile or internet
provider not only can they record your
browsing history they often will sell it
to other corporations who want to profit
from that information which is why I've
decided to take back my privacy I use
Express VPN expressvpn has easy to use
apps they do run seamlessly in the
background of my computer and phone and
tablet turning on expressvpn protection
it only takes one click expressvpn
secures it anonymizes your internet
browsing by encrypting your data it
hides your public IP address protecting
yourself with expressvpn it cost like
seven bucks a month expressvpn is ready
the number one VPN service by TechRadar
it comes with a 30-day money-back
guarantee so if you ever use public
Wi-Fi you want to keep hackers and spies
from seeing your data expressvpn is
indeed the solution and if you don't
want to hand over that internet history
to internet provider or data resellers
expressive VPN is the answer protect
that online activity today find out how
you can get three months for free at
expressvpn comm slash Ben that's exp
ress VPN comm / Ben for three months
free with a one-year package visit
expressvpn comm slash Ben to learn more
well ty thanks so much for stopping by I
really appreciate it thanks for having
me and so for folks who don't know the
eye Lopes is kind of the entrepreneurial
guru for probably hundreds of thousands
of people across the United States you
can see all of his his programs of her
title OPM he's a brand-new one called
knowledge Society we're gonna talk about
but I how did you get started in this
business because your career path shall
we say is is somewhat unconventional
yeah there's a personality test you can
take called hexaco it's the most
scientific one and one of the it puts
you in twenty five there's twenty five
traits in human personality this is the
most updated scientific test and one of
them is
openness to new experience in
unconventionality and dr. david buss a
mentor of mine he is he says its genetic
so my mom is a super hippie so I think I
became unconventional maybe in the womb
and maybe maybe it's something like that
but yeah I mean I think that at some
point in my life the most unconventional
part has been my education and how I use
the education system so I went through
the regular kind of education system but
then I was 18 graduated high school was
gonna go to college and a guy called me
up guy named Joel Salatin and said do
you want me to mentor you I'm doing a
six-month apprenticeship he had a farm
in Virginia it's like completely
different cuz I grew up I was born in LA
and I said I wonder if I should do this
my stepdad I had kind of a rough
childhood but one piece of good advice
my stepdad did he said you can always go
to college later you might not get a
chance to do a mentorship with this guy
and so I went up there for six months I
lived in a little cabin in his backyard
it's a 500 acre farm
I worked 12 hours a day for I ended up
being there for about two years and it
changed my life because instead of being
in a system where I had lectures and
professors talking to me and you're
partying and all that I was 20 or 16
hours a day with somebody 20 years ahead
of me and I did a TEDx talk and it kind
of went viral and I think the reason was
I told people if you want to do big
things in life you have to follow this
thing I call the law 33 percent so you
spend 33 percent of your time around
people with less accomplishment with you
those are people maybe you mentor you
help right then you spend 33 percent a
time around people who on your level
those become your friends people you
smoke cigars with or bubble cigars but
the last thirty three percent is what's
missing in education in society is where
you spend 33 percent of your time around
people twenty years ahead of you
shadowing them and I once in a few years
ago I made a list like everybody that
you think of as great people Albert
Einstein Stephen
Hawking Bill Gates Mark Zuckerberg Jeff
Bezos Warren Buffett and I was like
differ some of them went to college but
I was like what's a common thread that
they all have in it and found out that
Albert Einstein bumped into this guy I
think his name was max Levinson who was
a mathematician an older mathematician
every Thursday he would go to lunch and
talk math with this guy from age 16 on
Alexander the Great who maybe was the
greatest Conqueror of all time his dad
hired a mentor for him at age I think 14
to 16 and a pretty good mentor
his name was Aristotle and you know
Warren Buffett got a guy named Benjamin
Graham and as I went through the list I
found on the top 40 people that you
could say have done big things in our
time
I think 39 of them attribute a lot of
their success to Mentors
they don't attribute it to oh I took a
social studies class
oh I'm M Erised things in seventh grade
they attributed as somebody who kind of
held their hand in and and they shadowed
through education process so that's what
I kind of did it and I'm thankful that I
tried that approach I guess you had a
bunch of kind of interesting experiences
all the way through here I mean you
spent two years living with the Amish
Amish yeah how did you wind up moving
from two years of the Amish to you know
multi-million dollars here 500 acres
over in Virginia and yeah people off
would say they're like because I did a
video 2014-2015 with I had bought a
Lamborghini and I posted it and it ended
up I think the total views there's a few
versions of it is six hundred million
views on YouTube it's one most viewed
things besides music videos right so
people are like I joined up from no
electricity living like that for two
years to Beverly Hills and I'm like I
have no idea actually but life has lead
you down a path that you don't always
understand except in hindsight so I
guess in hindsight are motivated by
adventure one of the things a mentor
taught me is this thing that I call the
4ms blog people procrastinate if you
bump into most people I meet I've got
about 13 million social media phone
now so I get thousands of people asking
me questions every day and the most
common theme one of the most common is
how do I overcome procrastination fear
and anxiety my answer is like well you
got to know what motivates you and
different people are motivated in
different ways so the four M's
and I've run this by a lot of scientists
most of them think I'm on the right
track one of them just he thinks I'm
missing an M but the first M is material
things might slash money the second one
is mating slash romance the third one is
momentum slash freedom and and the
fourth one is mastery slash status if
you look at any person that you know and
you break down why do they do what they
do it's one of those four now dr. David
buss who's a mentor to me now he's used
to teach at Harvard and he's
evolutionary psychologist he said tie
it's all maybe all human psychology is
mating it has to be it's evolutionary
it's but I would say for me my number
one is this thing movement freedom and
I've kind of been a free spirit the
reason I went from living with no
electricity focused on you know living
in the country close to the land nature
to the city was I realize I need to make
money to have freedom an average person
in America I read saving about two
dollars for every hundred dollars I make
and that's a great way to create a
feudal society you know for every
hundred bucks you if you want to
guarantee Charlie Munger says don't try
to think out how to have a good life
he says use the principle of inversion
try to think how to have a bad life and
then don't do that
so guys you want to have a bad life for
every hundred dollars you make save one
or two of them and spend 98 and so I
grew up you know I was born to a single
mom my dad was actually in prison when I
was born I was born kind of an inner
city in Long Beach and growing up until
I met these mentors I was just kind of
floating around yes you're in school and
but they don't teach anything about
making money but just has to be the
biggest oversight in the solar system
it's like why do you go to school at the
core practical value because you have to
provide for yourself and your family for
the next 40 50 years do we equip you
with anything
old for that no we did you calculus
which will help you if you become an
engineer which I remember I was in a
class I remember learning in seventh
grade they made me memorize what the
California State bird was Cal I think
it's the California condor if I remember
correctly right um but I was thinking
then when I was like 25 I learned how to
invest in real estate in stock market I
was thinking I could have waited on the
California state bird like I feel like
you can learn that at 60 and you'll
still have an enriched life but you may
want to teach kids before they're 18
like how to do their taxes how to invest
how to do real estate how to sign a
contract
there's zero of that in school even in
college I hire PhDs that are just morons
or actually don't hire my interview and
I'm thinking get your money back son
there's there's one there's depend on
who you ask there's 1.2 trillion dollars
of recorded debt for college in the
United States and they think if you
can't untracked loans from parents we're
talking two trillion dollars in debt and
people are coming out knowing nothing
common sense is no longer a common you
know and so how does a society survive
that doesn't know how to take care of
themselves it ends up in a government
state that becomes a solution you know
Joel Salatin I'm not as political as you
or even my first mentor saltan but
libertarian and I tend to be more
libertarian probably partly because of
that but partly because it makes sense
and so now it's the replacement of
common sense with the replacement of a
big government that's gonna be the
common sense for you but it's not in
fact the government's designing the
school curriculum that says let's focus
on the California state bird and forget
the rest so I asked you about you
mentioned these four ends the motivating
factors so I'm gonna kind of softly
positive 5th mm which I think we're
under and I want to ask you about this
which is meaning so you talked about you
know the idea of mastery and you talked
about money and you talked about mating
and you talked about the any talk about
freedom essentially but where do you get
your meaning what what what gets you up
every day like what we can
have all these things and we do we live
in the virtual society in the history of
the world the free society in the
history of the world and yet rates of
depression are rising rates of suicide
are rising where are people missing the
meaning in life because you know as
somebody who's also very libertarian
minded I'm very much in favor of free
markets and I'm very much in favor of
earning an entrepreneurship we'll get
back to all that in a second but what
gets you up in the morning what what and
it can't just be money because you've
got a lot of it otherwise you would just
retire right right and it can't just be
freedom because the truth is that you've
got enough money to provide for you that
freedom what makes you think okay I'm
gonna get up today and I'm gonna go do
some work well what gives you that sense
of meaning so now we're going to the
deepest question of you know I'll give
you a I do a lot of book stuff I'll give
you what I think is the greatest answer
to this question and maybe the greatest
book that nobody reads there's a book
called civilization as discontents by
Sigmund Freud and Sigmund Freud's been
discredited in some ways
but the man may be the smartest person
you'll ever read if you read
civilizations it's condensed and he says
this question of what the meaning of
life is has been asked time without end
and nobody can give us a satisfactory
answer and he says maybe because there
is no answer but he says I can tell you
by the actions of we humans what our
meaning is and that is to be happy and
to avoid pain so it depends how deep you
want to go I'm probably searching for
happiness and at the core of every human
action of those for Em's people perceive
if I get money I'll be happier if I get
freedom I'll be happier so I used to
have a more complex answer but now I
give a cliche answer I'm probably
searching for happiness and avoidance of
unhappiness I don't know it's a good
question are we human so differentiated
that meaning is different for everybody
I don't know I think Sigmund Freud might
be right at Al Capone was seeking
happiness in a distorted way and so was
I just read the book of El Chapo dude
want to be happy he did it you know by
selling method and all this stuff and
and people like the Amish or deeply
religious people now the Amish it's
interesting you bring up depression knee
Jared Diamond who wrote Guns Germs and
Steel here at Harvard Pulitzer Prize
he studied Amish and he said they have
500 percent lower depression which is my
experience the Amish are the happiest
people and I think that the Amish are
happy I think they would disagree with
Freud so for the Amish life is is a
religious spiritual they're Christians
just very concerned they're Christians
how Christians used to be an 1800 Amish
are actually not as weird as people
think they just froze in time it's that
sad that seven days a week basically
yeah they're off with some morning it's
like a Jewish Sabbath just yet
so maybe better than so my humanistic
answer is I'm seeking to be a happy but
you know the Amish or their thing is
like there's gonna be another life after
death and so that's their meaning so
they don't take themselves maybe as
seriously on planet earth so I would say
I'm not as religious as the as the Amish
um but that's a good answer to if you
can pull it off I don't know that when I
live at the Amish I live when after
drill salads and I ended up at the Amish
for over two years and I actually own a
ranch in the middle of Amish community
now and I sometimes think that you know
that the Bible story of the Garden of
Eden right and some people think it's
literal and some people think it's
allegorical and but the story is that
they were in this innocent bliss then
they eat an apple and the Apple was that
from the tree of knowledge right also
they knew lots of stuff and because they
knew lots of stuff they were kicked out
forever and the flaming sword was there
and I kind of feel like for me since if
I had been born Amish and never seen the
outside world I could just be happy with
that but because I've been out in the
modern world there's like a flame now i
see the happiness that they have but i
can't get fat as a sword so uh maybe I'm
not as happy as them just a second I
only asked you about my mentorship and
entrepreneurship we'll get back to that
in just one second but first I want to
talk to you about zip recruiter hiring
is challenging but there's one place you
can go where hiring is simple fast and
smart a place where growing businesses
connect to qualified candidates that
place is zip recruiter
komm been guests because we have a guest
zip recruiter sends your job to over 100
of the web's leading job boards they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and invite them to
apply to your job as applications come
in zip recruiter analyzes each one and
they spout like the top candidates so
you never miss a great match
zip recruiter is so effective at 80% of
employers who post on zip recruiter and
a quality candidate through the site
within the first day with results like
that it is no wonder that zip recruiter
is the highest rated hiring site in
America and right now my listeners can
try zip recruiter for free at this
exclusive web address zip recruiter comm
slash been guest be Eng you est that zip
recruiters comm slash been guest zip
recruiters comm slash been guests we use
zip recruiter here at the daily wire
offices there's a reason we do so it is
because they do a wonderful job ensuring
that we get the best candidate zip
recruiter comm it is indeed the smartest
way to hire okay so speaking of
entrepreneurship let's get started with
that video that has 600 million views
here big reader obviously you've talked
about how you read a book a day what's
your technique for reading first of all
I see you're really busy ready you walk
around here you got a big crew and
you've got people following the cameras
all the time where do you find the time
to read a book a day how long does it
take you to read a book and how in-depth
oh you're reading it versus skimming it
how does that work so here's my thing on
but it's funny you're controversial on
many subjects my takes the books as
controversy if you can believe that you
have a cooler but a controversy story
politics is cooler in some ways but
books here's my thing most books suck
first of all so you don't need to read
as many books as you think so in a book
a day I often read some of the great
books over and over maybe once a year I
read civilizations discontents by
Sigmund Freud probably 10 times a year
it's that good so I think you have to
wait and when you pick up a book that
someone recommends and it's the book of
the day for me and I realize it's not
that good I don't finish it and people
think that's controversy at all time you
don't really finish a book a day I'm
like yes I did I got no only good the
rest of the book is just they couldn't
sell they had one good premise that was
eight pages and they but the publishers
like we can't sell an eight page book
for 25 bucks so fill it up with
anecdotal stories it's like when I read
these books now a lot I won't name names
what big names I'm going once I find out
their premise in the chapter I just move
on because I know they're only gonna put
stories in there supporting what they
said I'll join you in the controversy
I'm you know as I get older I have the
same experience when I was younger I
used to boil my way through everything
and now I mean I was in the middle of a
book the other day and it was a 500 page
book and I was at the page 350 dive in
normally I've been like okay there's
only 150 pages left go for it right
let's finish this thing through at page
350 I was like this is not worth another
two hours of my time I've gotten here
we're finished and put it down would I
hear you
that this is what Charlie Munger says I
really for business I think the greatest
business people of all time with Warren
Buffett and Charlie Munger and you know
they're they're not the richest right
now Jeff Bezos is but they own a hundred
brands they're the most diversified
people they got 400 billion to our
company keep 150 billion in cash these
guys are insanely smart and what Charlie
Munger says is most smart people he meet
understand the concept of opportunity
cost right people get it okay but he
said but no one implements it so when
you're reading a book and you're 350
pages 350 pages in and you realize it's
garbage but there might be a little bit
of nuggets in the last hundred 50 but
the last hundred fifty three hours are
reading
you've reached the marginal like that it
you're not a constituent and the real
cost is not those two hours reading that
it's what else could you be reading
there's over depending on who you ask
there's 50 million books been published
something like that more you're not
gonna finish them in your lifetime so
what you have to do is narrow it down I
actually have a free little thing I
don't make any money on it but ty Lopez
comm slash books I listed a hundred
books I think everybody should read and
I think you're better off in life taking
that top hundred and reading it over and
over because really good books Selfish
Gene by Richard Dawkins the one thing by
Gary Keller these books Contiki is a
great story like autobiography
if you read those books and you come
back once every two years and really
they have a whole new meaning for you
when you reread them so I ever taken the
approach of trying to read you know
everything people definitely don't read
what most people recommend you
definitely don't read what's at the
front of Barnes Noble Barnes and Nobles
always because they're pushing something
they're pushing whatever is painted put
stuff on they pay to put in the front
yeah you know if you're playing poker
and after 30 minutes you can't figure
out who the sucker in the room is you're
the sucker they put you there to make
money from you when you walk and bar in
the noble and you're like oh this book
appeals to me that they paid to have in
the front you're the sucker in the room
go to the back of Barnes & Noble in the
little psychology sections in history
sections and you find these books that
you're like this is the greatest thing
I've ever read so are those your
favorite topics the the the kind of
social psychology history what if you
have to pick topics you have it just for
fun to read what's your topic I mean I
love history but I do I love psychology
in the last I'd say last five years one
of the most critical mentors I ever had
and people a lot of people associate me
with making money and entrepreneurship
but this guy named dr. David buss if you
want to read a book that will blow your
mind his textbook called evolutionary
psychology by dr. David buss it's what's
used at Harvard and Yale and all this
it's insanely insightful basically
everything you've never understood in
life why people act the way they do
you'll be like that makes sense so I
like psychology because one of the
biggest things they didn't teach us in
school that they should have is how to
read people because almost every trial
tribulation traumatic event you have in
life it's not from an inanimate object
Barrett he knows people don't look back
in her life and be like you know what
sucked in my life I stubbed my toe I
broke my foot on a rock wall they like
most people's thing is like I married
the road they say the three biggest
regrets of people who they married the
career they chose and the education they
had like 80% of people regret those
three and to the extent you regret only
one of them you'll be happier than
people regret two of them most people
regret all three and the reason you
regret all three especially career and
who you marry is no one teaches you how
to read people most important thing that
could happen in school is learn how to
read people all the good things and all
the bad things will come from filtering
out the bad people before they get in
your social circle and bringing in the
good people I think of it like you know
those hamster balls put a little hamster
in a plastic ball and you roll him
around the reason you put on a plastic
ball I I didn't know as a little kid I
thought it was supposed to be fun and
then I had a friend who had a hamster
and didn't put it in the ball and he
stepped on it one time and I realized
wait a second the plastic balls to keep
the PAMP sir from dying we're the
hamster and so you need to have a thick
plastic ball around your life because if
the wrong people get inside that you all
again if I wanted to curse my enemy I'm
like may horrible people befriend you
become your business partners because
each of them will cause a
self-destruction in your life and no one
talks about how to read people I mean I
created this personality quiz this is
another little thing I don't charge for
it yet it's at Tai Lopez on slash quiz I
don't know if I'm supposed to plug these
no I don't have anyway I think about
three four five hundred thousand people
have taken it and without me advertising
it this is one of the first time as I
mentioned it on somebody else's show but
I took the top six scientific tests that
nobody talks about except in the
backhauls of psychology departments at
Harvard and Yale and I made them public
and it will and I tell people before you
have somebody be your business partner
how them take Tyler by the docks ah calm
such quick before you go on a date with
somebody be like hey will you take this
quiz it's insane the mental health
problems in the world right now it's it
that everything and to speak to politics
since that's a big subject of yours
almost everything people talk about in
politics is related to personality
traits for example being a Republican is
something you can test for and it's
probably genetic being conservative
there's a genetic component I'm not
saying that people don't choose I'm just
saying in general they call it our rwa
right-wing authoritarianism
um it's a Association and it's an
evolutionary reason you want a society
where some people say pick yourself up
by your bootstraps and go out and forge
your own path in the world that's more
of the conservative approach to life now
a democratic more liberal approach is no
we need meals-on-wheels we need this
safety net for people but that's a
personality trait that's why people
choose that it's more of a nurturing
estrogen type of response I'm not saying
everyone who's a liberal is estrogen
respond but there is something to that
and I didn't realize that till doctor
David buss is like oh yeah we can ask
people a serious question series of
questions and I already know their
political stance before I ask I don't
have to ask well then there's certainly
biological components to politics the
studies out the studies on it are well
there there are certain studies that
tend to be a little bit biased with
regard to self-quizzing for example if
you look at these tests that suggests
that authoritarianism is more right-wing
trait that very much is is tied to the
questions that are being asked we don't
ask for example you know do you think
that people should be shut down because
they don't believe in climate change
you'll see that the left suddenly looks
a lot more authoritarian than the right
is but there are there are certain
biological studies that are really
fascinating about for example if you if
you smell something dirty and then you
this for everybody if you smell
something dirty and then you ask people
how they would vote on certain questions
they suddenly become more conservative
because they're trying to avoid the
dirty
yeah and it's it's it's quite
fascinating that way so let's talk a
little bit at the mentorship stuff
because obviously a mentor box you have
all these programs that are you're
talking a lot about mentorship what's
the best way for somebody who doesn't
have a mentor to find one like for me it
was very easy my dad was my mentor
nothing for a lot of young men
particularly having a very involved
father is is a key to success obviously
not having father in home you're an
exception yeah it's it's it's but I
found fathers surrogate father
exactly so how can that happen for folks
who don't have either a father they can
trust with this stuff or a dad at all
yeah that is a good question here's the
thing Groucho Marx said he didn't want
to be part of any club that would have
him as a member right he's like if
they'd have me out a member it's too low
of a quality club he wanted to be in a
country club that he couldn't get into
it's the same with mentors anybody who's
like I'll gladly mentor you you don't
want them to mentor you because you're
like why aren't you busy you know why do
you have time to mentor me either your
93 years old and retired or there's
something wrong and so it's a catch-22
because you're trying to find people to
mentor you that really don't want to and
don't have the time so how do you do
that one I would say go to well first
first you have to know where do you want
to be in 20 years specifically like
you're in media so let's say you didn't
have a mentor and you were asking me
this question I would say where do you
want to be in 20 years who's the closest
to you who you want to be and let's say
the answer is I don't know who would
that answer be I have no idea anymore
closest even though there is nobody like
you would you would you want to have the
reach of a Howard Stern or a Rush
Limbaugh not the content but would you
want bad do you want to be a talk show
host like you wanna be like it I mean 20
years ago I would have said those things
right right now that that would have
been more what I would have said 20
years ago and you're right that I did
find people in this space just to try
and you know give me advice like I was
very when I was much younger one of my
mentors was Andrew Breitbart who was
very prominent in the space yeah when I
was younger I used to talk a lot with
with David Limbaugh who's the brush or
brother of Rush and he used to give me
advice and on the column side I was
friends with with Ann Coulter and folks
like that so yeah I mean as I get what
you're saying mean when I was when I was
a teenager I was looking actively for
people without your work your own path
yeah exactly yeah becomes harder for you
the law 33 percent becomes harder as
you're more successful all of a sudden
there's not a hundred people you can
look to yeah you have to compile them
sometimes you have to go Charlie Munger
says you have to look at the imminent
dead like you have to use books you find
people who went a Abraham Lincoln or
something like that yeah and I think
that it's changed for me a little bit
too in terms of the stuff that I envy is
knowledge in certain areas not even
effectiveness in certain areas we're
pretty effective at reaching people and
I'm not sure you know who I'd look to in
the space who is better than we are at
it but but there are certain areas of
knowledge where I feel like I lack and
so there I'm trying to constantly reach
out to people who know more than I do
and knowing what you don't know is
obviously a major area of being able to
find the right guy to teach you I think
yeah well I would say this is my simple
answer
talk to ten people with potential one
will say yes and that's where most
people mess up they go I know this
perfect person they go talk to one
person I'm like they're busy talk to ten
you'll get one if you want to mentors
talk to
you'll find - and your mentors will
change in the president United States I
think cabinet is 15
you need a handful a mistake is also
finding one mentor because then it
becomes cult-like you know you don't
want the cult like you wanted a a
cabinet around you of wise advisers and
an old proverb is make war with the
multitude of counselors and that's kind
of been my approach and so the other day
I was working on this real estate deal
as a mobile home park I was thinking of
buying I actually grew up in a mobile
home my teenage years and I was like
maybe I should buy a mobile home park
just to be like the true American
rags-to-riches like I lived in it and
then I ended up owning it but I have a
mentor who made one over a billion
dollars in that space in real estate and
I was gonna buy this place was in
Indiana flew out there and I was like
let me I was at veggie grill by Trader
Joe's on suds and I called him up and
then Richard I was at Richard should I
get this place and he goes I'm really
busy I don't have time to talk second in
just 30 seconds he goes okay I tell me
the deal details told him the high-level
details he got so into the subject it
was a one hour on the phone and he just
laid out exactly what to look for what
not to look for and I was thinking this
guy's 70 years old he just gave me
accumulated knowledge of 50 years
I just saved 50 years in one hour that's
a mentor so in a second I want to ask
you about your philosophy of
individualism versus and of
communitarian and we'll get into
politics which is my favorite space in
just one second but first let's talk
about your imminent death so you're
going to die sometime soon maybe not
that soon hopefully not that soon but
when you do plots you're gonna really
wish that you'd had life insurance I
mean if you're there after you're dead
you're looking around you're going what
did I fail to do life insurance might be
high on that list life insurance is
pretty important it's also confusing
which is why four out of ten people
don't have it and maybe you're one of
those people but if anything were to
happen it's important that your loved
ones are taken care of
besides life insurance rates were the
lowest they've been in 20 years the best
time to buy is right now the best place
to buy is policy genius.com policy
genius is the easy way to compare life
insurance online in just five minutes
you can compare quotes from the top
insurers to find the best policy for you
and when you compare quotes you save
money it's that simple policy genius has
helped over 4 million people shop for
insurance placed over 20 billion dollars
in coverage and they don't just make
life insurance easy they also compare
disability insurance and renters
insurance and health insurance if you
care about it they can come
so if you've been putting off getting
life insurance there's no reason to do
so any longer go to policy genius.com
get quotes apply in minutes it is that
easy you could do it right now and you
should because their rates are the
lowest they've been in 20 years policy
genius it's the easy way to compare and
buy life insurance again policy
genius.com okay so let's talk about your
politics a little bit you're very you're
very driven guy obviously and you're
somebody who's trying to encourage
people on an individual level to go out
and better their lives to me this max
obviously have a libertarian slash
conservative perspective is that where
you are and what do you make of where we
are politically in the country right now
except everything seems so fragmented so
divided and yet it seems like I've
talked to a wide variety of people
across a variety of political viewpoints
right here on this show I may have
talked to you and on the I've talked to
Jordan Peterson I've talked to Joe Rogan
I've talked to Eric Weinstein right just
a bunch of people from right right to
middle to left and all the severe II
successful people they all seem to have
this very individualistic perspective
even if they are Democrats where do you
think policy and politics and sort of
perspective on individual responsibility
where do those line up well I think the
first thing to know about politics if
you study history at all even at a minor
level politicians haven't been good
people for a long time they're probably
not gonna be good people I'm always like
amazed that people are like you're not
gonna believe this
I found out that this about Bill Clinton
or Donald Trump or Hillary I'm like
welcome to Planet Earth my friend have
you read it have you read a book this
has been going on it 2,000 years ago
1800 years ago 79 say so what happens is
going back to reading people
politics attracts a narcissistic people
and if you look at the donkey yeah I did
I'm seeing people running for all I got
ya I got don't worry not people
commented on it oh the people running
for office I would say Donald Trump is
the most classic example of a narcissist
I would say Hillary Clinton's a classic
example of a high Machiavellian person
possibly have not sure about cycler I
interviewed Hillary once about books
I kept away looks yeah a very smart
woman but you know she smacks of that
Machiavellian and all these people go
from NYX
and all of I just read a book about
Woodrow Wilson I mean the guy one of the
worst presidents ever to solve their
zombies that some love them you know my
grandma grandpa said Calvin Coolidge was
the worst the most corrupt but anyway so
my take is nobody cares about you as
much as you and definitely are not a
bunch of narcissistic politicians so if
you have much faith in the system at all
I think you're the sucker in the room
does that mean you should ignore
politics no cuz it's a necessary evil as
how I look at it do I put you know the
law of Pareto principle 8020 I think if
you put 20% of your focus on politics
and big system is the system and policy
and 80% in doing what you can control
you'll be good why do you think people
are putting so much focus on the on the
20% I mean it's pretty clear right now
people are distracting themselves to an
enormous extent with the give and take
of politics people are engaged like
they've never been which is great for my
business but it's not necessarily great
for their it's me if you're spending all
your I'm on Twitter or agonizing over
whether nuclear war with North Korea is
imminent when it clearly is not you know
then you might be wasting your time why
do you think people are so interested in
engaging with politics particularly now
I mean is it a lack of meaning is it oh
no I think it's uh I think well maybe I
think it's um a well veiled
procrastination it's for his well veiled
attempt at procrastination you just go
well I could focus on building skills so
I can make more money or I could whine
about this person not doing something
for me and it's much easier to do that
humans all if humans are like water they
always move downhill whatever is easiest
you don't see much water going I'm gonna
go up hill and so because people
procrastinate they've been looking for
external reasons to blame forever and
there are external that look bad
childhood
that is an externality you had no
control over who your parents were if
you had a traumatic childhood but at
some point you just grew up and you go
well I cannot redo that there is no time
machine
so I'm gonna pull them pull my pants up
my big-boy pants take the diapers off I
can go out and do what I can and what
politics allows you to kind of revert as
an adult you're like not blaming your
parents you're blaming Donald Trump I
promise you this presidents are less
important than people think they are
totally actively more less support on
individuals life even more you could
even argue that I think the biggest
thing that people should talk about what
interests me in politics and what really
moves the needle is demographics
study demographics you can go to predict
everything you can predict America's
aging Africa isn't Africa is a massive
growth rate um I went to India one only
had six hundred million people now India
has one point one or two billion two
Americas have grown inside India in our
lifetime
America the world by 2030 projected to
maybe be at eight point five billion
people it was at seven billion what last
year you're gonna grow five America's on
the same Khan the same set of continents
what's that gonna do all politics will
bend to that what do you think the
future of politics looks like that I
mean given the fact that our replacement
rates in the United States or well we're
actually higher than most of the
industrialized world the rest of the
industrialized world is kind of screwed
which is why they're bringing in
tremendous efforts of immigrants where
do you think we go here given the
burgeoning debt the aging population all
the rest of it man uh Will Durant says
nations are born stoic and die epicurean
maybe we become epicurean maybe we will
die out in something I I believe in
humans in the long run I think America's
so strong all right this is not my area
expertise so I'm gonna give you an
amateur answer my amateur answer is Will
Survive the media will focus on a
crapload of drama but there'll be
millions of individuals living nice
normal lives with happy families the
main concern I have I think mental
health issues is going up and if let's
say it's always been bad when my
grandma's a hundred by the way she was
born in Germany you'll like this
thorry my grandma was 19 years old her
friend said you got to come here this
guy he's a great speaker her name wasn't
maliit Amishman who wrote a book about
this now it's kind of a famous book my
grandma goes okay I'll go see him they
go down to the park car pulls up the
tops down a man stands up starts yelling
it was Adolf Hitler
my grandma's 19 she was born in 1918 so
I think this is 36 and 37 when he's like
Time magazine man of the year media got
it wrong there was oh my grandma goes
this guy's crazy
I'm leaving she goes to her family says
I think this guy's gonna declare war
he's just a madman I heard him talk in
the park five feet away from him my
grandma's family goes no no he'll be
fine yeah he promised you know he signed
a peace with Russia and pole he's not
gonna be pulling my grandma goes I'm
leaving anyway she gets on a boat as
she's on the boat she comes to America
it knows nobody he declares war and
invades Poland as my grandma's crap
crossing the Statue of Liberty she comes
to America knows nobody pulls herself
gets a job as a waitress ends up getting
a scholarship for college her life dream
was to go to California ends up in
California I like my grandma's story she
had foresight to see she was able to
read people first of all as I said the
course killed the man himself Adolf
Hitler in person she read this guy's
insane
she had foresight prudence she didn't
procrastinate Zizi procrastinate it's
hard to leave your country and so she
came here and she had low anxiety she
was able to overcome fear that's hard
fear drives people into the wrong corner
and she overcame that and I'm here
because of that and so when my grandma
was young there there was less there was
maybe a billion people on the planet so
let's say one person and people are
insane for sure 1% of population
psychotic so would you have a billion
people you're talking ten million
psychotic people spread over the whole
planet what happens if the rate still
stays at 1% but you go to eight point
five billion now there's 85 million
Psychopaths now what if also mental
health rates be
because of the disintegration of role
models family communities the Amish have
community now where there's too much
urban life in life is not as healthy as
you think I think you come to the city
to exchange ideas and then people should
live in the country it should be like a
nation states like Greece or something
like that whereas like country urban
country good blend that's what I try to
do now spent two weeks in Beverly Hills
New York City all this in two weeks in
the middle of nowhere on a ranch and so
because that's not happening and it used
to when my grandma was born 90% of the
world lived in countryside villages 10%
in large cities it's inverted now it
just in about 2015 it went the other way
I think mental health has gone up from
1% of people to be whack jobs to like
10% so I don't know how to say this in a
judgmental way like they're bad people
I'm talking about just like it diabetes
is something you feel bad that someone
has you don't go haha you have diabetes
there's people with legitimate massive
amounts there's so much anti-anxiety
medication being taken I just read now
Shadia graphic the Great Lakes of
Michigan it's got made its way into the
water through basically people peeing in
the toilet fish are so doped up they're
like have low anxiety and they're not
like searching for food anymore so
they're just dying you got 15 to 30% of
people clinically diagnosed with anxiety
what's gonna happen to a society I don't
I think like I said we'll survive but I
think that we should refocus on stuff
fixed education system focus more on
mental health not at a governmental
level but you know half the battle is
just tell is people realizing they have
a mental health issue they have high
anxiety they have narcissism just fixing
just realizing it is literally proven to
fix half of it but how much do you think
is this of this is the destruction of
social standards so you talk about the
strength of Amish communities I mean
obviously one of the strengths of Amish
communities the people are married and
they stay with each other and then they
have kids in them and same thing in the
Jewish community where you have you know
low rates of a lot of kind of social
problems they
in other communities because people are
expected you get married you stayed
married to that person you take care of
your kids that's the way it is you take
off every seventh day there's no you
have no electric no electronics what how
do you resolve the tension between the
need for freedom that you talked about
earlier this individualistic society
that we've created where we want to do
what we want without any consequences
yeah and the fact that we do actually
need to embed ourselves in social
structures that allow for us to thrive
because yes it feels restrictive but
it's also what it allows you to thrive
in a lot of cases yeah what does jaakko
will excite discipline brings freedom
there's more freedom from discipline
anything I would say I've gone through
different opinions on opinions on this
I've come around and I think you're
probably right
I think that when I was at the Amish
recently about six months ago I was
walking around and I was like why am i
happier and I was like I know why
bounded rationality so there's this
concept in science and in psychology
heuristics it's called how you make
decisions bounded rationality means if
you want to go get sushi restaurant food
someone says do you your wife or husband
let's go eat if you couldn't put bounds
on it you'll go crazy you know many
sushi restaurants there are in Los
Angeles you know if you wet okay which
one should we go to do we go to the one
in Whittier Long Beach it so we
immediately put one boundary on it
within five miles of our house then we
put another boundary on it okay Yelp
reviews need to be three stars or higher
so that puts another set of walls on it
then we put the last one it needs to be
open now boom and now it narrows it down
to two places and our happiness goes up
because we don't have that many choices
one of my mentors is the guy who wrote
paradox of choice and if you've read
that book he's a famous professor it's a
fascinating book he says the reason
we're becoming less happy as we have too
much choice used to only have choices
like Amish you basically marry a girl
that you grew up with there's 10 or 20
choices you have some choice but it's
not tinder where you go insane and if we
don't have bounds on our rationality you
become more unhappy and I've been
testing this recently I'm in LA I have
the whole world in front of me I can do
this and then I go to the forum where
it's kind of like I need to wake up at
five in the morning and I dress this or
you know you dress is more conservative
when I'm in all these boundaries
actually make me feel better
let's it let's talk about how you
structure your day because you have a
lot of advice for folks on sort of how
to live what's the most successful way
to live how do you structure them you
know again I see you walking around you
have a huge crew here you've got a
camera on you all the time travel a lot
your your your do it you're providing
all these materials at your web sites
how well buzz comm so how do you how do
you structure that day how do you decide
how much is fun how much is how much is
work and where did you cross over like
give me a give me a visual so I think
daily routine is important I think the
first thing for everybody that I follow
that everyone can read is a great book
by Gary Keller called the one thing it's
the power of focus first thing I try to
do is go okay I there's too much to do
what's the one Domino I push today that
knocks down like a hundred dominoes
because I do not want to push down one
hundred one at a time I got to hit one
huge one that's real heavy and it knocks
everyone down so I think you have to
know what your superpower is and do that
80 percent of the day I think as a Sikh
I used to believe in you know test
management systems and Excel
spreadsheets and you prioritize and you
flip it in every 15 minutes you do a new
thing and you do there's a thing you
know there's all these different tools
that people put forward to be productive
and successful but I started studying
people I'm like what does Warren Buffett
do this guy owns a hundred of the
largest brands in the world from Amex
Bank of America you know I'm going what
is this guy Geico what is he doing and
he says simple I spent eight hours a day
reading invest about investment deals
800 pages today that's it because you
want to see my his a little day planner
he loves to show it he's like 88 he goes
I wanna see my day planner what I have
scheduled this month he just laughs cuz
there's nothing for eight months on
there so I think the first thing is read
that book by Gary Keller the second
thing if I was advising myself the
second thing is less is more
do not confuse Flurry's aback
with accomplishment activity and
accomplishment both start with an A but
they are unrelated I have friends that
just oh my god I in fact I've found the
poor my friend is the if I'm like hey
can you come help me move I got a move
so I dude I'm just so busy I'm like
you've been in pull unemployed for six
months you have nothing you're lying
you have Game of Thrones to watch it
whatever but the reason ice its
causation correlation I'm like wait a
second I think the reason they're in
what they're in no one ever taught them
how to be productive and so they keep
them so busy with flurries of activity
but none of it moves the needle on life
and life you got only four things I
think I call them the four pillars of
the good life health wealth love
happiness physical health so what I do
this is my third point of being
productive I just think those are in
order so I try to do workout first
health you know I've gotten to know on a
Schwarzenegger a little bit not super
well but I was in his kitchen it was
like a 45-minute talk with them and I
went to Australia a couple months ago
give a talk with him and I asked him
this and he goes I wake up at 4:00 in
the morning time I read for one hour
5:00 in the morning I ride my bike to
the gym by 7:00 I've read an hour and
I've got you know I've got a two hour
workout in and eating breakfast
that's a productive guy by 7:00 in the
morning and so you do your health first
then wealth is usually people's career I
like to do it in the day then health
wealth love to me love is friends family
romance those three parts component
level so at night I pretty much do
something social every night and then I
say if you do the first three pillars
happiness comes automatically you got to
balance those first three so do them in
that order I meet people that spend all
day socializing with friends and they
you know entrepreneurs they put off
their work or IP people who put health
it and they lift weights oh I'm gonna
get it in before I go to bed no do it
first that's the order if you don't have
health you won't care about wealth love
or happiness because you'll be in pain
it for me that the the biggest thing
that I've realized and this is a real
change from earlier in my career is when
I was when I was a lot younger
the tendency was to say yes to
everything so yes I want to get together
people when I offer you something to do
for a career yep
you always say yes because you're so
eager to get going that you just say yes
and it turns out that if you want to do
work for free then there's lots of work
to be done for free and then I started
to realize that the more I said no the
more successful I was because number one
it creates scarcity in the market number
two you actually need some time to
yourself it's a great article in The
Wall Street Journal about exactly this
somebody wrote a long piece in the
review section about how it nobody
understands but people will say like you
have time for a 15-minute phone call and
they'll say no and they don't wanna be a
jerk about it but a 15-minute phone
calls not a 15-minute phone call all
right phone calls a 45 minute phone call
actually takes 45 minutes but because it
takes you 15 minutes to get into we have
15 minutes to get out of it and by the
time you get on to the next thing you've
wasted an hour so when you talk about
the day planner you know the most
productive days that I've had are days
when basically I get my work done in the
morning and then I've got all day to do
that stuff that I had that I really want
to get done for sure you know a good
bonus tip I'd give if I was advising
myself again at 18 take catch-up
vacations so Bill Gates loves to read
but he was running you know the 17 time
richest man in the world had a lot of
responsibilities he took vacations on
set intervals I don't know if it was
once a quarter or once every six months
and he brought all the books that he
couldn't read that he wanted to and he
would go through 17 books in a week
um I like to do these mini breaks I
usually use Palm Springs I recommend you
go at least an hour and a half from home
it can be drivable doesn't have to be
expensive get a cheap hotel can be a
little family vacation I go to a
relatively inexpensive place and I just
bring stack yellow notepads where I'm
writing out my plans you got to be the
general of your own life a good general
goes in the war room you can't always
have flurries of activity you got to
work not just on the you know in the
business you have to step back and work
on it and so I bring my yellow notepads
I bake bring books I bring no itinerary
and I just catch up and I think you
should do it once a month and you can do
in one day and that one day will pay off
by making the other 29 days of the month
at least fifty percent more productive
so where do you want to be in ten years
where do you want to be in ten years
you're looking at your career and
happier baby uh
I think you all should try to be happier
I think so when you getting married
that's a good question um you know it's
funny I need the grilling was coming
it's just a matter of Todd knew that was
coming
I think it's hard for me to get married
sometimes because I had half my foot in
the Amish world and in country world and
half my foot in Los Angeles so it's like
every time I meet a girl in LA that fits
in in LA I'm like here come to the farm
and they they're like oh I don't like
this and they were telling me a girl
who's in the countryside and likes
horses and like I got sixteen horses and
all this stuff and likes to work and
then I'm like let's go to LA they're
like oh I hate LA so I don't know man I
got my foot in two different worlds
maybe that's maybe maybe don't do that
uh so I don't know I don't know oh yeah
that's something that's on the list that
we gotta fix you up there we go a very
Jewish thing exactly I get you involved
in a religious community and fix there
we go let's talk about religion for a
second we bring home touched on it
before so where are you on religion you
mentioned your Richard Dawkins fan so
that gives it some some indication
they're not it well where are you and
God in religion but you spend a lot of
time with the Amish obviously I you know
I like the Amish I thought they were for
for Christians there this is gonna
offend a lot of people but they are real
Christians and I don't think I ever met
that before like people who actually
like Jesus Christ says you know if
somebody slaps you on one cheek turned
the other so they're all pacifists now
I'm not saying you I'm not a pacifist
but I like respect people who you fight
MMA in it yeah yeah they're not
hypocrites oh I like that if I would be
Christian I would probably be some
version of that ah this is a tough
question you're one of the only people I
ever asked me this that I let ask me
this a lot of people are gonna go right
to this part of the podcast I would say
that I think religions good he's better
than most people think so even though I
have a complicated you I don't think
most people should
have a complicated view I think it's
good to believe stuff even and I do
think it's okay to read Richard Dawkins
and it doesn't have to make you lose
your faith even the smartest people in
the world even Stephen Hawking level
people believing weird things like
multi-level I mean multi-level multi
universal the universe which is that MIT
so the thought that there's this
spiritual thing going on and there's a
God it it's kind of scientific in a way
I think that um in order to make
spirituality work and I think well I
doesn't work maybe from it hasn't worked
at certain times in my life and for
friends that I watch if you don't
remember that hamster bubble if your
religion lets to loose of a group into
it you will get disenfranchised you will
get disenchanted with the group so if
you could pick maybe it's what you have
small group of people that really do
what they say they're gonna do then you
can stick with it for a long time I
think you know you look at big mega
churches in America and Christian
churches and people go there and halfway
through it they're like wait a second I
know this person out here Monday through
Friday they're out drinking and you know
carrying on and then on Sunday I see
them in their very spiritual that messes
with people's brains so I think if you
can find a non hypocritical group of
people that it's very healthy and it's
probably healthier for kids to grow up
with the belief you know really so I I
mean I grew up judeo-christian I'm more
judeo-christian and funny even if you
try to not be judeo-christian if you
grew up judeo-christian you kind of are
yeah you know open America American is
it's I had this conversation with Sam
Harris sitting in that chair saying to
him no Sam it's very weird because Sam
of course is a militant atheist yeah and
and I was saying to him it's weird the
you and I shared 95% of the same values
and why is it that we share those values
and he gave a bunch of reasons why he
believed what he believed I said well
probably it has more to do with the fact
we grew up 10 miles from each other yes
in Los Angeles after 3,000 years of
common history probably it's bad so and
I certainly agree that
okay so from the divine to ridiculous
engagement you engage in culture as well
yeah so give me your favorite cultural
cultural totems like TV and movies
what's the viewing watch I mean I like
basketball I really like basketball
believe it or not uh yeah I played a one
of the top high schools in the u.s. in
one couple state championships in North
Carolina so basketball is my thing yeah
one of my favorite things about kind of
you know I got a hundred million people
that watched my videos every year
probably the coolest thing is I've made
friends a lot of NBA guys cuz they watch
my videos so uh that's that's you know
achieving some level of status is only
good if the people you admire admire you
back
like getting status at the wrong group
who's the coolest person that you found
out was a fan of your show this is one
of the cool experiences I've had is
you're sitting around suddenly you get
out wow that's gonna neat yeah some of
the Lakers some of the Clippers I've
become good friends with Chris Paul I
just did a little thing with him you
know so that yeah that's it I went I was
at a Laker game and I walked up to Kevin
Hart the comedian and I was just gonna
talk to him he goes I did this viral
video I gave away 11 cars to people over
last last year and so he came up to me
he goes for kid giving away cars ty you
should give away a house so he already
had watched my videos that was kind of
money Rihanna I did a little interview
with me on its how I you know I like I
like basketball cultural totems I like
actually like film funny I went ten
years didn't want any movies I thought
it was for idiots and now I'm like you
know what there's a value in being able
to escape reality and I've produced a
little bit of movies I've dipped my hand
in that I wouldn't mind you know what a
powerful movie impacts people more than
you think especially a powerful series
like a game of throw I think the way
they should teach history and in school
and I love books
forget books get these badass you know
series they have one called Rome mm-hmm
I think yeah man you'll remember more
about roman empire by watching that i
just watched one on the story of the
Trojan horse mm-hmm I mean I'm like why
didn't they teach me this in school and
I'm like they probably did but no Boram
ember that a good Civil War movie you'll
remember the Civil War nobody who could
in school they make you memorize 18
whatever 61 is 65 I'm going or was it
1862 64 61 to 66 165 okay 61 I was right
the first time and I'm going who cares
let's know that lets what was the Civil
War make a movie out that and all when I
watched those movies I watched that one
glory or whatever way man you you take
away things cool Denzel Washington
so so I'd love to make movies like that
I think they should make a movie about
World War one you know World War one is
the pivotal it changed the world that's
some of that's my favorite history about
when people say America doesn't like
World War one because we weren't in it
that long we didn't really get in until
1917 but my grandma it's wild my
grandma's alive out a hundred when she
was born this World War one was still
going as well she's born in February 20
1918 alidium some good genes on you ah
yeah I don't know but I don't know if
all be as healthy as my grandma she's
old school she's tough fights in the
nature she fights you know my grandma
does she's 97 I went three years ago
she's 97 and I go to visit her in San
Diego she comes out with a little
aerobics outfit and she had a headband
on oh my grandma where you're going he's
like she goes I have Zumba class and she
goes I'm going with all the younger
ladies and I was thinking is my grandma
going in the class with like 25 year
olds so I looked it up her little YMCA
class was 65 plus but when you're 97
she's like I'm going with the young
ladies the this so I hope me if I had I
told you how I would curse my enemies
bless my enemies may you be doing Zumba
at 97 exactly like my grandma well Tai
Lopez thanks so much for stopping by
it's really a pleasure as an hour that
flew so ty Lopez calm go check his stuff
out and he's got a ton of great stuff
there also you can check out Tai Lopez
comm / ben shapiro
young man they put up a landing page so
they can see who shows up go check it
out Tai Lopez calm tight thanks so much
for somebody thanks for
I appreciate it
Avenger Pierrot shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy borin associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stevens edited by Alex Singaram audio is
missed by Mike Hiromi no hair and makeup
is by Jess waffle Hera and title
graphics by Cynthia and Gullu Ben
Shapiro shows Sunday special is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright for publishing 2018
[Music]